our subject for this morning from
genesis
to revelation what did i say
from genesis
to revelation
and god spake all these words saying
i am the law of thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have
no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any driven
image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the law thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation
of them that hate me
ensuing mercy
unto thousands of them that love me
and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son
nor thy daughter thy man's servant not i
made servant nor thy cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
honor thy father
and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his man's servant
nor his maidservant
nor his ox nor his ass nor
anything
that is thy neighbors
god is good
and all the time
let's try that again as though you mean
it god is good
and all the time
good morning everyone
how are you
i'm delighted to hear that i'm also
blessed if you are alive you are blessed
if you can if you made your way to this
church you're blessed
if you're able to hear what i'm saying
you're blessed amen
if you can see me
you're blessed
you have some place to live you're
blessed
and so when my brother said i am blessed
i believe he spoke for all of us we are
blessed and we ought never to forget the
goodness of god to us somebody say amen
i thank god for the honor of being here
with you
it is a privilege to speak for god
and he has asked me through his servant
pastor burkitt to address you for this
coming week and my commitment to god
is to deliver thus saith the lord
as simply as i possibly can
and i will allow the spirit of god to
determine how you respond to thus saith
the lord i can only deliver the words i
cannot tell you how to respond
but i believe you will respond as the
spirit of god moves upon your heart
and so i thank god very much it is now
this like this short of
a little past 11
i will not hold you long but just long
enough is that okay
so that i can do the work of god how
many of you present now you are visitors
you are not selling the adventist merch
your health
you are not uh god bless you
thank you very much for coming and may
the lord grant you all the desires of
your heart anybody else you are not a
seventh-day adventist you are visiting
nice john
don't be afraid we're very nice people
in this church raise your hand let's see
your hair anybody anybody else sister
what's your name
mary
oh my that's a good name
you are the mother of jesus mary
it's nice to have you please come again
mary we'll be here all week i will look
for you again mary where are you from
summersville
how far away is that from uh chestertown
okay so not too far all right
i'm from ann arbor michigan but
originally from barbados in the west
indies a little island this wide and
that long and but a lovely little place
so there's no other visitor among us all
right are we online pastor are we being
streamed let me welcome those of you who
are connecting via facebook or youtube
or zoom or whatever it is we thank god
for technology that allows someone to
stand in chestertown and be heard in
kenya or arabia or wherever else we
thank god for technology the good side
there's also a dark side to technology
but i wouldn't get into that all right
our subject for this morning from
genesis
to revelation what did i say
from genesis
to revelation
now before i begin can you do three
little things for me
let me check my form make sure it's off
if you're not using this
to read the bible make sure it's turned
off
so that we don't
disturb god you know god is holy
come on somebody say amen for god
god is holy and god loves reverence he
really does
and so please preserve reverence as we
worship the god of heaven and earth
pretend you are in a courtroom
would you get on your phone in a
courtroom
no you'd make sure it's you would
perhaps they would not even allow you
to bring one of these and when i go to
the city hall in my town you've got to
check your phone you can't take it in
you've got to check it you cannot take
it in and so if we can pay that kind of
respect
it's a sinful human being surely we can
show god some respect can i say can you
say amen all right
number two while i'm speaking pray for
me all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth
and i want to speak god's words
how did christ raise lazarus
he spoke
his words then can
cancel death
how did god create heaven and earth
his word his word then can create
how did god cast out devils
by his word his word can get the devil
out of you can you say amen or out of
your children
yes how does god forgive thy sins are
forgiven thee by his word
how did god heal
by
his word and so i want to speak what the
words of god because my words cannot
raise the dead
or heal the sick
and so from time to time simply say lord
put your words
in that man's mouth
the third favor i ask
think
as you listen
concentrate
thinking is not an automatic activity it
must be deliberate and conscious
think
i've often said and i'm sure i'll say it
a lot more times if we would think
we would not eat some of the things we
eat
if we would stop and think we would not
drink some of the things we drink if we
would stop and think we would not date
the people we date are you following me
let us
if we would think we would not attend
some of the churches we attended
if we would stop and
think
what am i
doing think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together saith the lord let's
borrow heads as i pray dear god
i need your help
i am made of dirt
and i cannot handle spiritual things
unless i have power from above
i ask in the name of jesus christ dear
god
help me
to deliver your words of life
so that first you are glorified
and second your people are blessed
if i have sinned against you forgive me
your bible says
if we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive
now father use me i pray
bless those who are listening whether in
person or online wherever they are bless
them their god
give me simple language
that the truth may reach every listening
heart of every age
bless this church
bless the sister church
bless your manservant you've chosen to
lead your people
grant him always wisdom from above and
all the officers who serve with him
bless your people wherever they are on
this earth day god wherever your people
are worshiping you now bless them and
put your words in the mouths of the
speakers
hear this humble prayer father i offer
from my heart in jesus name let god's
people say
amen and amen
our subject is what from
genesis
to revelation
go with me to the gospel of john
chapter one
we'll read from verse one
john is different from matthew mark and
luke
matthew mark and luke together are
called the synoptic gospels why because
they tend to see things alike the word
synoptic means generally to see alike
optic have eyes optician sin
together similar
seeing things together matthew market
but john sees things very very
differently so john is not a synoptic
gospel his view of christ is just
different
let's see how he begins as he introduces
christ john 1 reading from verse 1 the
bible says in the beginning was the word
and the word was with god and the word
was god stop
whenever the beginning was and we're
human beings we cannot fully understand
eternity
we cannot fully understand what
everlasting me i've heard many
christians say what will i do in heaven
i'll be born stiff living there forever
and ever with no football and no
basketball
but we have a different minds we will
not be bored stiff you cannot be bored
stiff living in the presence of someone
who can raise the dead send bread from
heaven bring water from a rock you
cannot be born stiff in his presence any
more than you're bored in the presence
of a magician
in the beginning
what's the word
what is this word read verse 14 for me
of john chapter 1 as we continue with
the subject from genesis to revelation
what does verse 14 say and the word come
on
became flesh and dwelt among us
who was that
jesus
now take that information from verse 14
and put it into verse one
read first one with me now in the
beginning was
jesus christ
and jesus christ was
yes
so when you read in the beginning was
the word and the word was with god and
the word was god you probably read in
the beginning was jesus and jesus was
with god and jesus himself come on was
god that still is
i pause for you to swallow that
jesus christ
has always been there
verse 2
the same was in the beginning with god
who is the same
jesus
now read verse 3
all things were made
come on tell me
by him if you are the king james version
and without him finish the verse was not
anything made that was made with you
remove christ nothing exists
i appreciate that amen but did you
understand what i said
remove christ
and nothing can exist
all things were made
by him
who is him
jesus
and without him
was not anything made that was made read
verse 4
in him was
life
and the life was the light of men
what have we learned
jesus has always been there with the
father and he is equal with the father
it is he
who created heaven and earth and nothing
exists without christ
and here's life
this is john introducing jesus
he is describing that man who walked the
streets of galilee
that was the mighty god
from way back now let's look at another
book written by the same author
first john chapter one we'll read from
verse one our subject from genesis to
revelation
first john chapter one
reading from verse one
it's almost 11
i'll let you out in good time please
don't panic
you have first john 1
well when the preacher asks you a
question you must answer him do you have
first john 1
all right from verse 1. are you there
let me pray again father as i continue
speaking to your beautiful people
tell me exactly what to tell them
that you may be glorified in their lives
in jesus name i pray amen
first john 1 verse 1 that which was from
what the beginning which we have
heard which we have seen with our eyes
which we have looked upon and our hands
of handle come on of the word of life
for the life was manifested and we have
seen it and bear witness and show unto
you that eternal life which was with the
father and was manifested unto us stop
this is no different from what we read
in john 1
verses 1 to 3 or 4.
listen carefully
that which was
from the beginning
now john is a human being that's the
best he can do
but he was someone who said in john 1 1
in the beginning was the word that's the
same man writing amen
but he's more personal
in first john 1 he says that which was
from the beginning which we have
heard which we have seen with our eyes
which we have looked upon and our hands
have handled of the word of life
what is john saying the mighty god who
always existed
we saw him
we heard him
we held him
who is the president of the united
states
don't know
who is our president
have you ever held his hand
have you spoken face to face with him
who's the queen of
england have you ever held her hand
she's at a palace
he's in the white house
who is the god of the universe
were they people who held his hand
yes
now
john said that which was from the
beginning which we have heard
what is this called
it's the ear but what's we use the ear
to do what
and what is that
we have five of them what is that
a sense
am i too far from you
are you hearing me
is this mic working
all right what is
this okay what is that called the sense
of hearing john said that which was from
the beginning which we have
[Music]
this is no guesswork this is not gossip
we heard him
which we have
seen with our eyes is this a sense yes
is this a sense yes which we have
handled is touch ascent yes or no
we use our senses
god knows we're limited
it is god who gave us hearing seeing
smelling tasting touch for them four of
them of the five are located on the head
god presented himself in a way that
limited human beings can understand and
can testify we heard him we saw him we
touched him where we smelled him
because all people perspire
who is that the god from way back
give me a name
jesus
i get all the right answers from this
side
what's wrong with that side
are you sleeping with your eyes open
who is this god this side be quiet who
is this god
jesus
jesus the son of god now
john said i heard him
i saw him i touched him
he calls him that eternal life john is
emphasizing what he said in the gospel
of john jesus is the mighty god who has
all ways existed
let's go to hebrews
hebrews 1
we thank john for what he wrote but
there's someone more powerful than john
that's god the father
let's listen to what god the father says
about god the son
hebrews 1
we read 10 to 12. now i want you to read
microscopically
concentrate as you read and the spirit
of god will teach you
you have hebrews 1
nobody answered the preacher i see this
is a cultural thing i'll have to live
with it okay
all right
god bless you
you have hebrews 1
let's read from verse 8 remember now
this is god the father speaking but unto
the son he saith thy throne read with me
now
oh god
is forever and ever a scepter of
righteousness is the scepter of thy
kingdom now this is god the father
speaking
he is speaking to the son
tell me what he calls the son
he calls him god
what else does he say about the son in
verse 8
what is forever and ever
thy throne o god is for ever and ever
what is the throne suggesting to us
then what is the father saying about the
son he has always
ruled of course with him
the father is testifying the son has
always ruled i all o god
is forever and ever now let's skip to
verse 10
of chapter 1 of hebrews read with me and
thou
lord in the beginning come on has laid
the foundation of the earth and the
heavens are the work of thy hands now
what is god the father saying about
jesus
you're the creator
he didn't say
we have laid the foundation he said you
look at verse 11
read nice a lot if you have a kingdom
they shall
perish but thou remain now wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
when something perishes what happens
it comes to heaven
the father says they shall
perish who is they
everything yes the heavens and the earth
we're just ready for stand when you read
concentrate we read in verse 10 thou
lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of thee earth and the heavens
of the work of thy hand we have earth
and woven
now the father says in verse 11 they
shall perish who is they
heaven and earth
finish verse 11 but thou
shalt remain now what does that mean
he'll never pass away
the father is saying the son
will never pass away
they shall perish
but they are reminisce and as a vesture
shall well fold them up and they shall
be changed but thou art the same and thy
years finished verse 12
shall not
fail
the father is saying you have always
been there you will always be there now
you may argue with john you cannot argue
with god your father
let me pause
what have you learned so far about jesus
tell me this side somebody else
say it's just to say
he has always been there that side what
have you learned from what we've read
somebody tell me quickly
he is god
as much as the father's god say yes
quickly yes
what else have you learned anybody
he is the creator of what heaven and
earth
what exists without his creation nothing
that's jesus
also something
from genesis to revelation now we have
located jesus way back are you following
me we've located jesus way back
then we located him
at creation
are you following me at creation let's
go to psalm 90.
what's our subject
okay
you pause before you answer me i want
you to be quicker than that
let's go to psalm 90 we'll read the
first one
it's 25 minutes after 11 don't panic i
know there's a
potluck you know i don't just love
potlucks but it's okay
this is a better potluck can you say
amen this right here
this potluck will take you to heaven
that one
okay
uh
pray psalm 90
first one do you have that
let me ask you which one of you so far
has prayed for me said lord put your
word uh ah
god bless you god bless you the rest of
you who have not done it yet i'll do it
before i finish
lord
thou hast been our dwelling place come
on from in all generations before the
mountains were brought forth or ever
that has formed the earth of the world
even from come on everlasting read with
me through everlasting finish the verse
thou
art god no who is that
jesus
who formed the mountains jesus that's
what the father said in hebrews 1
now that psalm 90 was written out by
david but by moses
moses is acknowledging christ
as the one who formed the mountains and
he said long before you created you have
been there from everlasting come on to
everlasting let me ask you this how long
is everlasting
but moses doubles it
are you with me
now you're not with me
you're nice looking but you're not with
me
are you with me
moses said you have been there
from everlasting
this is the best moses can do to express
the truth that the creator christ has
always been
we've located jesus
before creation always existed with the
father we have located him
at creation
let us go
to exodus
3.
we read from verse 7
of exodus 3
and god said i have surely seen the
affliction of my people which are in
egypt
and i've heard they've seen the
oppression by reason if they cry for i
know their sorrows god says i see the
suffering i know
and i'm come down now to deliver them
out of the hand of the egyptians and to
bring them up out of that land onto a
land flowing with milk and honey onto
good land and enlarge under the place of
the canaanites and the hittas and the um
rights of the parisites and the
heavyweights and the jebusites god says
i am coming to deliver them the question
is who is that person
let's go to verse 13.
now god tells moses go talk to pharaoh
listen to moses
and moses said unto god
behold when i come unto the children of
israel
and shall say unto them the god of your
fathers have sent me unto you and they
shall say to me what is his name what
shall i say unto them
moses said god give me a name because
they have forgotten you
god said unto moses
i am
that i am and he said thus shalt thou
say unto the children of israel finish
that verse i am have sent me unto you
now when moses said give me a name
of this god who is commanding pharaoh to
release the israelites what name was
given to moses i am
go to the gospel of john
gospel of john
let's go to chapter
five
six let's go to six
let's read verse
48. what does that say
i am the bread of life i am the bread of
life
go to 51 what does that say
i am the living bread came down
from heaven all right let's go to john
8.
let's read verse 12
then speak jesus again unto them and
said what
i am the light of the world go to john
10.
i am the door
i am the door of course he is also the
good shepherd later on in that chapter
jesus is the bread he is the light he is
the door he is the shepherd go to john
14.
well no no before we get well let's go
to john 14 then we'll come back to 11.
john 14 3 6.
jesus said unto him what i am the
the
and the
now here's how you can say i am the way
i am the truth i am the life
so we see all these i am i ams i am go
to john 15.
read first one come on first one
i am the true vine
now
the biggest one of all let's go back to
chapter 11.
of john we read from verse 23.
you have john 11 verse 23
read with me jesus says unto her what
thy brother shall
rise again martha said unto him i know
that he shall rise again in the
resurrection when at the last day jesus
said unto her verse 25 what i am the
resurrection and the life
stop
i am the resurrection of the life now
go to john 8.
john 8
our subject from genesis to revelation
let's read from verse 56
your father abraham come on
rejoice to see my day
and he saw it come on
and was glad versus heaven
come on read for me
then said the jews unto him thou art not
yet 50 years old and has now seen
abraham read 58 now carefully slowly
microscopically
jesus said unto them
verily verily i say unto you come on
clearly before abraham was come on i am
now what was the name god gave moses
i am what does jesus say of himself
before abraham was born i
am
who is the i am that spoke to moses in
the exodus
jesus
we have seen jesus
way back before creation
we've seen jesus
at creation it was he who said let there
be light we've seen jesus at the exodus
name some prophets in the old testament
quickly quickly prophets
isaiah another one
jeremiah jeremiah another one
amos another one
joel another one
elijah another one
elisha another one
samuel another one
jonah another one
micah another one
nahum another one all right stop showing
off okay all right we thank god for
these prophets
god bless you god bless you now let's
learn something about these men as they
wrote the books go to first peter
chapter one
first peter one do you have that
you ought to be quick this is the
seventh-day adventist church
we used to be called the people of the
but we're not called that anymore and
that's not nice
we should get back to being the people
of the book do you have first peter
chapter one
now peter is telling us that the
prophets of all when they were writing
they wanted to understand what they were
writing
but they did not realize they were
writing for somebody else not for
themselves but they really wanted to
understand they wanted to know when this
god would come and walk on the earth
they wanted to be alive when that
happened
let's read from verse
nine of first peter one what does that
say receiving
the end of your faith even the salvation
of your souls of which salvation the
prophets have inquired and searched out
diligently who prophesied of the grace
that should come unto you verse 11 now
read slowly searching what come on or
what matter of time
the spirit of christ which was in them
did signify when it testified beforehand
the sufferings of christ and the glory
that should be revealed now
when isaiah was writing
who inspired him
look at verse 11
and i will not tell you the answer find
it for yourselves
the spirit of christ
who inspired ezekiel
now
we have located christ
before christ are you with me
i didn't hear you
all right
we have located christ at creation
we've located christ
at the exodus
now we see christ working through
all the
prophets
name the first prophet
it's good when you can correct yourself
yes enoch was the first prophet
do you realize enoch and adam live
together for 300 years
you didn't know what i said
when enoch was prophesying adam was
still alive
what spirit was working through enoch
the spirit of christ
who was the last prophet of the old
testament
now
who who worked through malachi the
spirit of christ
what's our subject
from genesis to revelation what do we
have
jesus
before genesis what do we have
now let's go to the gospels
let's go to matthew 1
it's 25 to 12.
who has to go to work immediately after
the service
okay
so if i take an extra five minutes you
won't be angry with me
okay what book did i say
one chapter
let's read from verse 21
what's our subject
okay
let me pray again father
as i continue this
message
remind me i'm here for your glory in
jesus name i pray
amen
the angel is talking to joseph in a
dream here's what he tells him verse 21
if you have the king james version read
with me and she shall bring forth a son
and thou shalt call his name
jesus come on for he shall save his
people from their sins by the way that's
why christ came one of the reasons to
save us not in our sins
he came to save us
from our sin so if he takes us from sin
he must take us to something else
i didn't say that clearly let me try
again
if you're drowning
and you're safe you're safe from the
where's the drowning taking place in
water where are you taken to some dry
land somewhere some ships on board
you take it out of the water the place
where there is no one amen if you're
saved from your sins christ takes you to
a place where there is one no sin
because you can be drowning in one sin
ah
you miss that
you don't need ten sins to go to hell
one
how many did adam commit before god put
him out of the garden one
so christ saves us from sin
to
a life of victory over sin all right
she shall bring for the son thou shalt
call his name jesus for he shall save
his people from the sins now isaiah 45
christ is a savior isaiah 45 let's read
verse 22.
you have isaiah
big book 66 chapters
second largest book in the old in the
entire bible which is the largest
psalms yes
well largest chapter yes 119. yes
longest book 150 psalms all right here
we have isaiah 45
verse 22
read carefully
read with me now
look unto me come on
and be saved all the ends of the earth
why
i am god
and there is none else
let me give you a few seconds to look at
that verse
what does god say he can do in that
verse
save now what else does he say about
himself
so what is he saying come to me
and be safe because
because
listen to me careful
i can't let you go you must give me the
right answer
listen to the verse again
he is the old who said that
i like you he is the only one who can
save and so he said look unto me all the
ends of the earth now what does he mean
is he talking to black people yes or no
yeah white people yes or no poor people
yes or no indians yes or no russians
come on japanese koreans huh
all of you look to me
i'll save you
because there's no one else
that just hit me
who is that go back to matthew 1 21.
you have matthew 121
not yet give you five more seconds
this is an adventist church do you have
it now
read with me my version and she shall
bring forth a son come on thou shall
call his name jesus why he shall save
his people from their sins
this is the person who spoke in isaiah
45 22 who was that jesus christ who
spoke to isaiah
now
verse 21 says she shall bring forth a
son
what does bring forth me
give birth
can you give birth to spirit
don't pause can you give birth to spirit
always speak with confidence even when
you're wrong are you following me now
can you give birth to the spirit yes or
no no
can you give birth to human being yes
what does that tell you about that god
in verse 21
he was human
but what else do we know about him in
verse 21 he will save
but he was the same one who said in
isaiah 45 22 there's no one else but me
who can save so he's god
but look at verse 23 it really settles
the matter for us
behold a virgin shall be with
and shall bring forth her
and they shall call his name
which being interpreted is
god with us
how did god come to us in verse 21
he was born
god asked me to explain that is the
greatest mystery of the bible
that the mighty god
whom the angels worship
was always existed
humbled himself
and came
as a
baby i cannot explain how god existed as
an embryo
and was born
and his mother breastfed god
may we change the diverse
of god
put a name to that god
jesus
why
for you
don't look at the person next to you
even if it's your spouse
all this was done
for you
amen
where else have we seen him from enoch
come on
to malcolm
now where is he in the gospels we have
this jesus
now let's go to revelation 22.
let's go to revelation 1 revelation 1.
we read 17 and 18 of revelation 1
let's read from verse 10 of revelation
1.
are you there
if you have my version read with me i
was in the spirit when
on the lord's day name the lord's day
quickly
the seventh day sabbath and heard what
behind me a great voice as of a trumpet
saying what i am
the alpha omega
beginning in the end
now here's his voice
let's skip the rest of 11 go to 12. what
does that say and i turned to see the
voice that speak with me and being
turned i saw what
seven
yes but that's generally specific where
is he looking
the holy place that's where the seventh
candlesticks were seven golden
candlestick and in the midst of the
seven candlesticks come on one leg under
the son of man clothing the garment down
to the foot and burned about a pack for
the golden girdle now who is he looking
at jesus but let's confirm that read
from verse 17. and when i saw him what
happened
i felt my feet and his feet is dead and
he laid his right hand upon me saying
unto me what
fear not i am
first and the last and he that
and was
dead
this is jesus
he came to john
all books of the bible culminate in
revelation
here's jesus
who started everything in genesis
he's bringing everything to an end in
revelation
now go to revelation chapter 22 the last
chapter of the bible
it's the quarter
let's read verse
of revelation
22. what does that say
he wish testified these things saith why
surely i come
quickly who is speaking
jesus
let me pause
what do you think i'm trying to get you
to understand by this message
anybody tell me
christ
is the one from where that
our finite minds have to use the word
beginning we cannot understand someone
who has simply always been there we
cannot understand that we accept it by
faith and so we use the word beginning
because our minds are limited
jesus christ with the father and the
holy spirit
some what have you what do you think i'm
trying to get you to understand someone
else
all the scriptures
now we start with enoch being the first
prophet
but what's our subject
who wrote genesis
was moses as a prophet
yeah so when was the spirit of christ
working from genesis
to revelation
what else do you think i want you to
understand
it is uh who said that
right i like that man nice tie
it is all about
jesus
but we learned he was born what does
that tell you about jesus
come on i'm a human being he was born
what does that mean
he's like me
let me ask a question was jesus 12
come on speak with confidence was he 13
was he 14 was he five
was he 20
he's an example for every age of human
development amen
and at every stage
he was both human come on
and god
now
i cannot understand what it means to
give birth to child i have no clue and i
want no clue are you following me
my mother could explain that when she
was alive
every mother listening to me can explain
that
i can't
because mothers have the similar
experience they understand
you have a baby in a cradle you have men
and women passed by the baby the women
react differently
is that
googling
over the baby the man the way a woman
will act differently because she
understands
jesus became
one of us
human
who became human
the one who said
let there be light
who became human
the one who parted the red sea
who became human the one who made heaven
and earth
who became human the one who brought
manna
from the clouds
this is jesus
now listen to what the bible says about
christ go to first corinthians 1
let's read verse 30 this verse is one of
many that talk about jesus and all that
he means to us first corinthians 1
verse 30. now you have to read this
verse very very carefully it is
awkwardly worthy
first corinthians 1 verse 30. when you
have that say amen
all right some of you still looking
you have it now
if you have my version read with me but
of him are ye
in christ jesus who of god committed to
us now
wisdom and
redemption and sanctification and
christ has said to us wisdom
redemption
sanctification righteousness he is all
these things to us
you need wisdom
where do you go
and how do you go to him
the word yes this
you want to do well in your studies at
school
the fear of the lord is the beginning of
knowledge where should you start with
the person who originated every branch
of knowledge except crime
are you following me
jesus
he is made unto us
wisdom
redemption
righteousness sanctification redemption
he's made unto us all these same no
wonder jeremiah says of him in jeremiah
23 says and his name shall be called and
this is the name whereby he shall be
called the lord our right he is our
righteousness your power over sin is
jesus
your wisdom to make the right decisions
is jesus
your humility is jesus
there is a man
called jesus who is also tell me
god
here's what he can do
here's here you are
here's god the
father here's jesus
no man can come to the father but by me
jesus as a human being takes your hand
jesus as god takes the father's hand
and in him he connects the two of you
answer this question for me
if god is in you
do you have power to conquer any sin yes
or no
yes
if god
is in me
do i have the power to conquer my short
temper yes
if god is in me do i have the courage to
stop working on sabbath yes
is there god
who understands what i'm struggling with
yes
is there god who can do something about
it yes
is there power to break me free of
pornography yes
name that power jesus
is there power to help me stop beating
my husband yes
what's that power come on jesus
is there power
that can help me to obey my parents
yes who is that power jesus and is there
a power that can strengthen us and take
us through coffee restrictions and
omicron restrictions and whatever else
is coming what's the answer yes who is
that power jesus
and so the bible says
for god so loved
the world
but let's
forget the world for a minute for god so
loved
me
that's not selfishness that's biblically
correct that he gave
his only begotten son
if you had one shirt
and somebody knocked on it says uh
that's the bucket i don't have any
clothes can i have a shirt would you
give it to him my answer would be no
i only have one
if i had two okay
but i only have one
are you following me
god had and still has
one only begotten son listen to what the
bible says for god so loved the world
that he loaned his only begotten son
correct me quickly
he gave
so what is christ a gift
do you take gifts back
do you realize christ has been given to
us forever
that's why he still has human form
he took human form back to heaven with
him glorified of course
which is what we will have when we write
jesus christ
right now
is human
while he's also god
where is he sitting
on the right hand of the father that's
the position of power now it doesn't
mean he's actually physically sitting no
it simply means he has occupied a
position of power from which he
represents us
if you had a housing problem
and your brother was in charge of the
department of health housing or whatever
else would you be at ease yes
my brother will work it out are you
following me
come on are you with me
my brother is the secretary for housing
so i really have no problem i just call
him
i don't have to go through any secretary
he comes to my house
there's a god
who's your brother
his name is christ amen
he has all the power in the universe
when he arose in the grave
and he gave his final words the
disciples we call it the great gospel
commission
and jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me
in heaven and in earth it means
everywhere
god can give us power so that city
council does not mess with us
god can defend his church so that the
government cannot mess with the church
there's someone who looks just like you
in the godhead
his name come on
it's jesus
and there's someone in the godhead who
looks like the father his name is jesus
he can represent the father
he can represent us but always remember
it was the father who sent him
the father is not our adversary it was
the father who sent christ so we have
father and son united for our best
interests
and so before i close i make an appeal
to you
re-commit your life
finish my words
to jesus
if you're asking how you just say
you say father
thank you for this word
i see christ a little more clearly
i read commit my life to him
let him come into me
dwell in me
i direct my life don't try to explain
how it happens
just believe
that it happens you simply say in your
heart all of it father
i recommit my life to you send your
spirit the spirit of christ to come into
me and to direct me
how many of you will say father i
recommit my life to you can i see your
help
god bless you i believe you stand up
with me
get bald eyes closed
dear god
we thank you for jesus
we thank you that he has always been
there with you
he is as much god as your god
he is defined
and by your arrangement with him
he became human
lived a victorious life as an example
for us
and now dear god he offers us that life
of righteousness as a gift through faith
in him
forgive us their god for many years of
doubt and disbelief and unbelief not
realizing that faith is the avenue
whereby we access this power
we recommit our lives to your father
and we ask you to fill us with the
spirit of christ
that the life of christ may be lived
through us as it did in the life of paul
as paul said i am crucified with christ
nevertheless i live yet not i but christ
liveth in me father of heaven and earth
we want christ to live in us through the
spirit
give us giving to us dear god by giving
us his spirit
bless everyone who listened in person
and online
let us daily day god daily
renew this relationship with our savior
fill us with a love for righteousness
and a hatred for sin
we thank you for the gift of your son
jesus
we love him
and we love you
watch over us for the remainder of this
day god i pray for my heart
in jesus name let god's people say
amen
and amen you may be seated
just before i close let me ask you a few
questions
what will you take from this message
anybody tell me what will you take with
you you will meditate on something you
heard
jesus somebody else
christ in me the hope of glory
not christ next to me christ in me
when christ was on the earth the
disciples were with him
he was not in them are you following me
through the spirit christ is enough so
jesus said he shall dwell with you and
shall be in you
you didn't hear what i said
through the spirit
christ is closer to us
than he was to the disciples
what else will you take from the message
he will save you from how many sins
all
who else can save you from sin nobody
else
what else will you take
victory
he gives you
you don't win the victory you receive it
by faith
are you following me you receive it you
know you can't make yourself drunk
alcohol makes you drunk what do you have
to do you have to receive it then when
it is in you it does this work are you
following me we receive the spirit of
christ when we do that it does its work
anybody else what will you take from the
message
come on
say it again
he was from everlasting to everlasting
and will continue to be from everlasting
to everlasting
somebody else
i can overcome now
you could we are to overcome
now
one more
jesus is the central figure
of the entire bible
search the scriptures for in them you
think you have eternal life finish the
verse and there are they which testify
of me
now by the grace of our lord jesus
christ from the love of god
and the fellowship of the holy spirit be
with us now and forevermore let god's
people say amen and amen
this belongs to somebody
or just leave it there all right
[Music]
you